this is his eighth season in Arizona he is
the longest tenured current coyote three
to one coyotes dancing Cooley score
scores what a goal of a youngster
Cooley comes right back follows
up the coastal 4-1 Arizona
so it was Cooley on the turnover but right here
is an example of why you live with mistakes
from young players look at this I mentioned
earlier that he's a dancer watch the dance
move right there and then gets himself in
a position when he spins the second time
he's in a perfect shooting position [Applause] and
he uses everything to hoist that puck quickly to
the top of the net that is something you cannot
teach that is pure skill big smile coach says
you know what you may have turned it over earlier
but right now we're gonna allow what you're doing
because he took that win and Bill Armstrong to
jam not as quite as smiley as to her knee but
I'm sure just as happy well that might be
in the top five highlights for the coyotes
for the entire season I mean that's hard
to beat that move those moves by Cooley